on today's visual studio toolbox ed
Charbonneau is going to show us how to
set our Blazers to run hi welcome to
visual studio toolbox I'm your host
Robert Greene and joining me today is
edge Charbonneau hey ed thanks for
having me Robert welcome back it's great
to be back
Ed's a developer evangelist with
progress software and a regular guest on
the show but it's been about a year
since you were last on it has been I've
been working hard on blazer for that
entire time so a year ago
you and Sam bazoo did an episode on
blazer I believe it was one of our long
ones it was an hour show cut and go to
bite-size back when we used to do our
long shows and so it was an introduction
to blazer and today we're gonna take a
look year later and you're you're gonna
catch us up to speed on some of the most
frequently asked questions that you hear
some tips and tricks the people doing
blazer would need to know yeah but
before we dive into that let's do a
brief refresher of what is blazer yeah
so we like you said we took a look at
blazer a year ago was a very early beta
back then it's now rolled into the
official asp net core pipeline so blazer
is a brand new front-end development
framework so a spa framework that uses
c-sharp full-stack so we can actually
write client-side application code with
c-sharp and not have to rely on
JavaScript
like we normally do with the jquery
react or angular we now Blazer to take
place of all of that and we have dotnet
and end cool so we saw it early last
year a lot of things have happened since
then and every time I present on blazer
I get asked these questions that are
really great questions but just at a
glance you don't quite catch when you're
talking about Blazers so I thought I'd
bring some of those questions up with
you today yeah cool let's do it all
right so I'll hit one of them ones that
is the most popular question I get and
that is does I
work with blazer now people usually
frame that question is does
authentication work with blazer an
authentication is actually a browser
behavior so that's usually happening on
the client but what they usually mean is
does identity does Microsoft identity
work with blazer and actually now it
does so with server-side blazer shipping
an asp net core 3 Oh Microsoft identity
will be available with the application
and if you click file new project just
like you do with an asp.net MVC
application or razor pages application
you get the dialog in the file new
project where you can click to change
your authentication type you get that
same experience with blazer and what you
get out of the box is actually what we
have running here and just like in an
MVC application you have your login and
your register links at the top of the
page so we can click login and we get
prompted with the identity log and
experience and I don't have an account
so we can click register and create a
brand new account and just like with NVC
or razor pages we can create an account
here and what I want to show if I can
get a correct password through this
through the system here I don't remember
what their requirements are now we get
an error screen or what looks like an
error screen but it's actually something
very helpful and MVC does this as well
and says data operation failed
processing requests because we haven't
created a database yet okay this is a
brand new file new project experience
but what's nice is we get a button on
the air page that says apply migrations
if we click it will actually create the
database for us
Microsoft identity database it will
apply the migration to our database
create all the tables we need and then
it will bring us back into the
application see this try refreshing the
page so we can come back it continued
and now we're actually logged in this is
hello ed Charbonneau met progress comm
so we have identity working it's backed
up by sequel and any frame
and this comes out of the box with a few
button clicks during the file new
project experience so this is a generic
and than any provider can hook it up to
Active Directory um you can hook it or
Azure Active Directory you can hook it
up to a sure and that steps you through
as well in the file new progress project
experience okay one other notable thing
that that's really interesting about the
way identity works and laser right now
is another question that I get asked a
lot and that is do Blazer components
work with MVC and can you mix MVC razor
pages and blazer in the same project so
if we go under areas and identity and we
look at our pages in here our logout or
login pages these are actually razor
pages so we have razor pages that exist
in our blazer application and they're
able to work side by side now another
thing is people ask can I use razor
components or blazer the component
framework inside of an MVC or razor
pages application and that kind of ties
into the same idea if we go into our
host CS HTML file so dot CS hTML is a
razor pages or razor in VC view inside
of here this is the bootstrapper for a
server-side blazer project but this is a
razor page and if we look right here
this is where the application starts up
and we have inside of our app tag an
HTML helper that says HTML dot render
component async this render component a
cig method is something that we can call
and bring razor or blazer components
into MVC and razor pages views cool
that's another frequently asked question
that's basic aynd of tie together in my
opinion you talked about using all of
these all of asp.net in a blazer
application and that is possible cool so
the next thing that I wanted to show
people ask frequently because they see a
blazer component I
you can refer to these as Razer
components the Razer component is
something that is the component model of
blazer so blazer components Razer
components kind of interchangeable okay
but when they look at one of these it's
all written in c-sharp and your markup
and your code is all in the same file so
one of the questions I get right away is
can I separate those two things so I
don't want my markup and I don't want my
c-sharp code intermingled so I've got an
example here where I've already started
taking these two things and decoupling
them so we'll finish this up here and
what I want to do is I have a fetch data
component and I have the code section
down here what I want to do is remove
this code section so the first thing I
want to do is create a c-sharp file and
I want to name this file the same as my
component but with the extension dot
razor dot C s okay so what that does
that matches up with our component file
name so our component is fetch data dot
raiser our code behind is going to be
fetch data Razor CS that allows the two
to nest in Visual Studio so when we name
them like that that semantics allows
that nesting to happen so we get this
nice tree effect where we can collapse
that code behind down if we'd want to so
I'm gonna click on fetch data razor dot
CS and this is the same code that is
inside of that code block and went ahead
and moved it out to keep this nice and
short okay so in fetch data dot razor we
can now take out this code block because
we have that in our code behind file so
to marry those two things back up
together we simply come back up to the
top here and we just call inherit so we
have an inherits directive and then we
point to that code behind file so this
is called fetch database the component
name is fetch data so this is the base
of that component so we'll save that now
I can also remove this dependency
injection
from it because that now happens in the
code-behind so now I've tied those two
things together in all of our little red
squigglies have gone away and we've
separated those two pieces of logic so
our markup is in one file logics and the
other so you named that fetch database
yeah so this this file is the file name
itself is fetch data dot raiser that's
yes okay to provide that nesting but we
can't call it fetch data because it will
collide with the component namespace
right so we can't have to fetch data
classes okay so we got to give it
something is a partial class it's a
separate class excellent question or
observation partial classes aren't
supported yet okay but it is something
that may come in the next release of the
preview okay
so fetch database was just a naming
convention that you use
it's a naming convention that I use and
it's pretty common okay it's a community
right now is to give name that as your
base of the component itself okay I
partials may be coming soon so this may
change a little bit over time but this
is one way that you can separate those
out today hmm
also we need to inherit from component
base on that so give this all the
lifecycle methods and everything that is
part of the component it's nice
so another notable piece is the inject
parameter here so we're injecting
through a property injection when we do
the code-behind
versus when we're on the mark-up side we
use an inject directly instead okay so
that's one piece that that people look
for when they start refactoring this out
is they don't know how to inject that
properly so the inject attribute on the
back backend side and its inject
directive on the front hand side okay
okay so that's one of the pieces that
people ask a lot about then you would
expect ultimately that that would just
be an available refactoring inside the
visual studio editor
so so might be a nice feature request
would be a good feature request there's
a lot of tooling changes that will come
with all of this new blazer style I've
talked with with Daniel Roth and in his
team and they're very optimistic about
what they can do with the razor engine
itself and there's a lot of tooling that
can come in the future cool all right
all right so we can look at some more
frequently asked questions another one
is we get this application out of the
box we need to rerun that we've done
some code changes here we'll pick this
back up and run it and we have this
counter component that comes out of the
box and the count starts at zero if we
click on the counter this is all file
new project experience so anybody that
runs Blazers probably seen this counter
component before if we go back home and
then we visit the counter page again our
state is going right so the components
don't share a state if I created more
counters they don't share that count so
we can have multiple counters on the
page they would all have their own
independent counts so how do we manage
state if that's something that we do
want so there's actually two ways to
handle state and well there's multiple
ways to handle state and Blaser I'm
going to show you two of them there's
actually some components that are
designed for this so we'll look at a
component approach and then we'll look
at using dependency injection and do
some application state so one thing I've
added to this project and under my
shared folder I have a component that I
wrote very simple one is called
counter state provider so this is a
provider component that I can plug into
my application and anything that is a
child of it will receive the values that
I assign okay to this component so it
uses a special blazer component this is
something built into the system called a
cascading value component inside of the
cascading value component I can provide
child content that's essentially what
this component is for anyway
and on value I'm gonna keep this as
simple as possible and I'm just gonna
sign this so this components value will
be just assigned to the cascading value
any child component can subscribe to
this value now hmm so what we'll do is
we'll take this and we'll put our
current count for a counter component in
that object so what I need to do to
implement this is I'll go into my main
layout and now I can surround any piece
of HTML in my application that I want to
be able to receive this data from so
we'll go right around the main component
of our application and we'll call in our
counter state provider and we'll wrap
that around the body of the application
so this is now at the application level
this is at the root of our pages so
anything any of the pages that we load
will be inside of the pot okay so now
anything that's in the body which
includes our counter component will be
able to receive that so how do we
receive that inside of our component so
there is a special parameter that we set
up and I'm going to use a shortcut here
and we're gonna use the cascading
parameter attribute on a property and
we'll set this up and call this current
count or actually what's we need to
bring in the the component namespace
because this is going to resolve to a
counter state provider and then we can
name it and when we'll name this let's
keep this simple and just call it state
so this state will be assigned the value
of this that it brings in from the
counter state provider hmm so now we can
consume it we can get rid of this
current count equals zero and when we
increment our count
we'll use the state instead so we'll say
state dot current count that's coming
from the state provider okay and up in
this section we'll do the same thing
state dot counter current count mm-hmm
so that should tie it all together and
now when we run our application we won't
lose that state as we go from page to
page we can also take advantage of that
so now we have our current count and go
to our home page go back we still have
all four mm-hmm make this a little bit
cooler on our index page we can consume
that same state provider so now we have
shared state across the application so
we'll do the same cascading parameter
it's going to be a counter state
provider we'll call it state and then in
my hello world section here I can just
write out current count at state current
count just like that and now this will
appear in our home page so now we're
getting the count off the counter even
though they're not on the same page
together so our current count is 0 if we
click this up let me go back cool our
home page was so that's one way that we
can share state across the application
this is using a piece of markup the the
value the the state provider uses the
cascading value component okay so this
is markup driven we can also do this
through code so we don't have to have
this markup piece that drives the state
management so in my application I've
added a very simple poco object plain
old class object called counter State
and I have a current count on that as
well this is something we can just
inject in our application through
dependency injection so if I go into
startup dot CS I'm gonna scroll down to
where all of my dependencies are
registered and in services I'll just
uncomment this line that I've added
earlier this services dot add scoped of
type counter state so now I have this
object this counter state that is
available to my application through
dependency injection so if we go back to
our counter component
instead of using a cascading parameter
we'll come up to the top of the page and
we'll use the inject directive and we
can inject that dependency injection
that counter state through dependency
injection so we'll call a counter state
and I think I'm missing a namespace here
this is in data data counter State and
we'll simply call that state again so
since we named it the same we actually
don't need any code changes here I can
remove this and now our data is resolved
through a dependency injection instead
has the same same idea but it's
application level and then in our
startup dot CS we'll go back here for a
moment
he used ad scoped to add that to the
application we have several ways to add
things to our container we can use add
singleton add scoped the reason I chose
add scoped versus add singleton so on
server-side blazer you're sharing that
application state with the entire user
base if you use add singleton okay so
that will be a single instance per
application not per user so it's a very
important thing to know you don't want
to share certain things with everyone
right
whereas our weather forecast Service
something is pulling in weather data we
can share with all users because it's
going to be the same okay
so those are some of the most frequently
asked questions that I get when I
present on blazer people ask about state
management they ask about identity and
they ask about code separation those are
the real heavy hitters that I get all
the time so that clears things up yeah
that's awesome so if someone who is
starting out with blazer what are
briefly some tips and tricks on how to
get up to speed on it how to get used to
it how to understand what it is not to
use it so my biggest advice would be
first of all to go to blazer net and
walk through the getting started
materials the.net Doc's team they've
done a fantastic job there okay
second of all blazer is a lot different
from MVC we're in MVC applications were
rendering strings blazer has something
called a render tree that it builds it's
not a string it's a representation of
the Dom the document object model that
is held in memory and it does diffs
against it to see what's changed so it's
a big difference from HTML helpers and
razor views that just render out strings
all the time okay the reason for that is
those string rendering mechanisms the
client-side code is done in JavaScript
so it goes back and it finds pieces of
the Dom manipulates it at its it deletes
it those sort of things in Blaser we
work with the render tree the developers
do and then the framework takes the
render tree and applies the changes for
us that's what allows c-sharp to be able
to work right on the client side cool
and your impression of how far along
this is is it preview you can you put
stuff into production with it in
September we will see a ga release okay
so it's coming soon for a server-side
blazer we'll have the global
availability soon client-side blazer
will come sometime next year we haven't
got a solid date just quite yet her I've
heard quarter one quarter two so the
that is coming soon and it requires
dotnet core yes sir blazer requires
dotnet core okay it's currently on set
for dotnet core 3.0 mm-hmm client side
will block like home with dotnet 5 ok
cool thanks for that thank you very much
hopefully everybody found you know
something useful out of this it's
getting started with this stuff is a
little you know tricky it's a it's a
brand new preview so I figure that most
people are new to the concepts because
the framework is news right something
I've been working on very closely
for the last year because of my job with
progress we we build UI components for
everything so we jumped on the bandwagon
early and right created a suite of
telluric UI components for blazer
my main focus to that in the show notes
along with places people can go to learn
more so hope you found that useful and
we will see you next time on visual
studio toolbox
[Music]